Make your romance an affair to remember with a surprise marriage proposal.
These ideas will help you catch your love off guard.
You will need: Secrecy, randomness, timing and creativity.
Step one: Tell no one.
Even if friends and family don't slip up with words,...
...they could give away the surprise with their behavior.
If you need help with your surprise proposal, ask people who don't know your intended.
Step two: Propose during an unplanned moment:...
...a random day at a nothing special location that holds no meaning for either of you.
It's an easy way to pull off a surprise marriage proposal.
They won't be expecting it.
Step three: Plan a romantic evening or weekend getaway.
Something that has "wedding proposal" written all over it...
...and then pop the question the day after you're back.
Step four: Be creative.
Make an online video proposal and have a friend send the link,...
...saying it's a hysterical video they've got to watch.
Or try a twist on the restaurant proposal.
Arrange for the server to bring dinner on a plate that has "Will You Marry Me?" written on it.
The message will slowly reveal itself as your future spouse makes her way through her meal.
90 percent of women surveyed do not want to be proposed to at a sports event via Jumbotron.
Step five: Incorporate your proposal into their daily routine.
A marriage proposal will be the last thing on their mind, so it's sure to be a surprise.
Good luck!
Did you know?
One in four women hated the way their fiance proposed to them according to a survey.